Russian president Vladimir Putin is trying
to reassert his authority after a weekend
of chaos in the country. On Tuesday, he told
Russian forces who faced Wagner valiant that
they virtually stopped a civil war. Yevgeny
prigozhin is one of the few Russians to
have openly defied or criticize Moscow. And
the war in Ukraine apparently without much
consequences. CNN's Fred pleitgen has more on
the fate of Putin's other critics in the past.
[Applause]
>>
A March of justice is how Wagner's leader,
yevgeny prigozhin, justified it. Fair others,
such as Russia's leader, Putin himself. This was
betrayal. A red line not many dared to cross.
>> All those who deliberately chose the path
of treachery, who depend paired an armed
[3:29:36 AM]
who depend paired an armed
mutiny, who chose blackmail,
and terrorist methods, will face punishment,
and we'll answer to the, law and to our people.
>> Just as quickly as the insurrection became
reality, a deal was brokered with the Belarusian
president. While the situation appears defused
for now, many who dared to defy Putin paid a
heavy price. A fierce Kremlin critic, Boris,
was once one of Russia's promising opposition
leaders. Jailed several times for speaking out
against Putin's government. But in 2015, on a
Friday night, just steps away from the Kremlin,
he was shot and killed. A dissident voice,
silenced. Five chechen man was later found guilty
and sentenced to over a decade in prison. Opposed
to Mr. Putin's role, threaten his establishment,
and life can turn into one behind bars. Once the
most wealthy man in Russia, former Kai to cross
the line with Putin when he began to tow the line
with our reforms, and accuse him of corruption.
[3:30:36 AM]
corruption. He was charged with tax fraud,
something he says was politically motivated.
Putin, the prime minister, was asked about
the case and replied the thief should be in
prison. The maximum prison sentence was given
to crack, and he spent years behind bars.
Alexei navalny, a staunch Russian opposition
leader, fell into a coma, returning to Moscow
three years ago. He was later medevaced to
Germany where he recovered. And investigations
later concluded he was poisoned with lemon
nerve agent. Navalny vowed to keep fighting,
an opposition to the Kremlin lingered, and as
he landed back in Russia months later he was
arrested. Now held in a maximum security
prison, navalny faces a term extension,
that could possibly see him behind bars for
decades. It's a fate seen many times over
when someone crosses Mr. Putin, and not all
can escape, it's not even living in exile.
Wagner's yevgeny prigozhin may have found a haven
and Belarus for now. But his safety seems fragile
[3:31:36 AM]
But his safety seems fragile for now.
At best. Fred plankton, CNN, Berlin.
>> Ukrainian foreign minister, dmytro kuleba, says
officials expected an inside rebellion against
Moscow. But did not know when it would happen.
CNN's Erin Burnett sat down with an exclusive
interview with the minister. Who says prigozhin
may have been the first, but certainly will
not be the last to defy the Russian president.
>> Has the rebellion in Russia, as you have seen
over just these past few days, I know there's
still the pug fog and chaos a bit. But has it
changed anything on the frontlines. I talk to our
Ukrainian drone operator operating near bakhmut,
he said on Saturday, they felt a palpable
panic for the Russians. But then subsequently
returned to what he said would be, quote
unquote, normal. In terms of their behavior?
>> If this mutiny had lasted
for 48 hours more, I think, I'm
[3:32:38 AM]
for 48 hours more, I think, I'm pretty sure,
that we would have felt a demoralizing impact
on the Russian forces fighting
in the south and east of Ukraine.
Unfortunately, prigozhin gave up too
quickly. So there was no time for this
demoralizing effect too
penetrate Russian trenches.
But nevertheless, this was not the factor that
our voices were counting on. It was like a force
measure, so it doesn't change anything in our
plan. So we can continue our counteroffensive.
>> But the foreign minister admits that Vladimir
Putin still has one card under his sleeve, marshes
nuclear weapons. He warns it is a game that
western countries do not want to play with Moscow.
[3:33:38 AM]
to play with Moscow.
>> In the context of Putin situation
right now. Do you think that his decision to use
nuclear forces in some way is a real possibility?
>> Frankly, I believe that the fear of nuclear
weapons is the last argument that Putin has in
his pocket. I think it's nothing that more than
a fair game. Because Putin loves life too much.
>> Even if his power is threatened?
>> And people around him love life even more.
And of course, where not -- tough
forecast future developments.
But the west we'll make a big
mistake if it decides to played